[Music]
good afternoon everyone I'm Gerardo kpl
and I lead product management for
consumer payment products here at Google
and with me is my partner in crime for
Roush Italian who leads the engineering
side payments are at the heart of
commerce if I want to buy a cup of
coffee I got to pay for it payments are
that link between desire and fulfillment
and that link is paramount to making
your apps grow and your businesses
thrive unfortunately that link is also a
major pain point for many of you
particularly on the mobile web where
conversion rates are a third of what
they are on desktop we're constantly
thinking about how to make payments
easier faster and safer today we're
going to be talking to you about the
foundation that we built with Android
pay and about how we're expanding our
API to enable richer commerce
experiences both online and in-store
take it away baruj the foundation as
Gerardo mentioned is Android tape our
solution for fast and secure mobile
payments over the past year the team's
been working around the clock to scale
this foundation globally and I'm so
proud to say that Android pay is now
available in ten markets but we're not
stopping there in the coming months
we'll be launching in Brazil Canada
Russia Spain and Taiwan so the momentum
of the traction is just incredible
[Applause]
I'm personally very excited about Brazil
because it will be the first Latin
American country and I really want to
visit there we're not just strengthening
the foundation by expanding it we're
strengthening it also through
partnerships one example of this is a
first provisioning API
these api's allow issuers to embed core
Android pay functionality directly into
their own apps so that for example in
this case a discover app user can simply
click the link for add card this will
provision their card to their device and
they can go into the store tap and pay
to purchase a good without ever having
installed the Android pay us the issuers
that have integrated the provisioning
API is to date have seen phenomenal
success and we're really proud of this
API
we're also strengthening this foundation
by partnering with app developers we're
doing this through the Android pay and
app API so that thousands of apps have
now integrated with and this these api's
are bringing seamless streamlines and
very smooth checkout to these apps that
are integrating for example the jet comm
app is seeing a 3.5 X conversion rate
increase just by implementing these in
app API in their checkout flow we're
also expanding this foundation to the
mobile web and we're bringing Android
pay to the mobile web and we're doing
that through the payment request API in
Chrome so we're very excited about that
and recently Washington Post integrated
with these api's and they've seen very
nice success with the streamlined and
native experiences that they're seeing
in their mobile web checkout flow we're
very excited about all the moments and
we're seeing in
building this foundation that we've
built over the past year now I'd like to
pass it over to Gerardo so you can talk
about how we're building on top of this
foundation that we have so we can expose
our users even greater mobile payment
experiences throttle thanks Rouge great
so let's start with online as many of
you know having a streamline checkout
experience is critical
for your website's to grow and for your
business to thrive we want to make it
easier for you to make it easier for
your users to transact online and not
have to deal with onerous forums and
we're going to do that two ways first
we're collaborating with a major payment
platform
last year we announced initiatives with
Visa and MasterCard and as you might
have heard entry doors keynote earlier
we're adding PayPal to that list as we
roll out each of those integrations
users will be able to link either visa
checkout master pass or PayPal to their
Android pay account and they will enjoy
a streamlined authentication and payment
experience and the best part is they
don't have to do any additional work if
they're already accepting visa checkout
master pass or PayPal so let's take a
look at how that works
we flip the phone please right all right
so it's starting to get hot out there
already summer is around the corner and
I'm starting to think about it's time to
spend some time around the pool so what
is it what do I like to have around the
pool well margarita that's for sure and
so earlier today I went and started
looking looking around for some
margarita mix and and I have some in my
shopping cart right here skinny
williams-sonoma margarita mix William
Sonoma great ecommerce site and so I
think I have enough margarita mix and
now I'm ready to check out so down here
I see a visa checkout button now when I
click that button
voila I see the cards I'm already logged
in and I see my visa cards already I
didn't have to enter in my username or
my password it's that simple and the
best part is to finish I just apply my
fingerprint and voila again I'm done
just a really fantastic experience and
like I said the best part is that
williams-sonoma already has visa
checkout so when we roll out that
integration and Android pay users link
their visa checkout account to Android
pay they'll be ready to go nothing else
to do but we're not stopping there as
you probably heard earlier today our
users have saved hundreds of millions of
payment instruments to their Google
account and they do that when they're
making purchases on Google Play on
YouTube or transacting in Chrome and the
benefit of that is that they get a
simplified checkout experience on future
purchases it's really great experience
so what if
we could bring that simplify checkout
experience to your apps and the websites
that you build well as hopefully you
heard in the earlier keynote today we
announced the Google payment API and
when you implement that API your
customers will be able to quickly check
out using any of the cards in their
Google account just super simple and
that's going to work as I said in apps
on the web and as you'll see in a bit
the assistant so let's take a look at
that so I'm going to pop over here and
let's bring it back
rate and I'm going to fire up one of my
favorite apps the wish app and which has
been testing this API with us over the
last couple of months and so I was
talking about summer the pool I need
some pool toys I love this inflatable
lounger but unfortunately last year I
jumped off the diving board belly
flopped onto the lounger and pop it so I
need another one so I have it in my
shopping cart already ready to go and if
I see at the bottom of the screen
there's a pay with Google button when I
click that button I see one of the last
card that I use but if I click further I
can see all the cards in my Google
accounts including those that I added
through Android pay hit continue and
voila again transaction is complete
it's really fantastic super simple love
it so in the next few months we're going
to be piloting the Google payment API
with a number of leading merchants and
apps and we want all of you to be able
to pilot this app and implement it and
to accelerate that process we're
partnering with leading payment
processors such as Braintree and stripe
advantage a CI adian first data and
WorldPay we're really excited to see
what you all do with the API and what
fantastic conversion rates you get soon
we're going to be uploading our
developer documentation and in the
meantime I encourage you all to go to
developers.google.com/live
this also works on websites so tomorrow
morning I would encourage you all to go
get a cup of coffee free on us you don't
have to pay for it and go to the future
of web payments session on stage six at
8:30 a.m. but if you can't get up that
early and I'll be up that upset early
I'll be there we have office hours at
9:30 a.m. tomorrow
and at Friday at 11:30 a.m. hope to see
you all there so now that you've seen
how easy it is to do transactions on the
web and in app let's talk about how
seamless transactions can be in the
assistant so I hope a lot of you here in
the crowd own a Google home and if you
do you've hopefully had the opportunity
to buy
everyday essentials from over 50
merchants including Whole Foods and
Walgreens soon we're going to be adding
even more merchants who have integrated
with our google shopping api's but we're
taking it one step further we're also
going to enable you all to build
purchase actions with the assistant and
in case you didn't see it at the last
session here's how it works so the user
simply says I want to talk to Panera
they specify what they want to order
Panera might even suggest some drinks
that they might want to go with that
order and then the user is able to
complete the transaction using the cards
in their Google account and authenticate
with their fingerprint that simple
fantastic experience so now you see how
we're making the assistance and even
greater platform for commerce
Wow Gerardo that was super cool how
about we use the assistant order some
Panera for after the session okay but um
let me pay you back for dinner I don't
want it to be just on you and what I can
do is I'll send you some money using our
new gmail send money function not
everyone's seen that feature before how
about you pay and I'll show the audience
something really cool that no one's seen
before okay who wants you something
super cool come on let's do it
all right so let's move to cast one
there you go
okay google send ten dollars to Gerardo
for dinner
yet
whoo awesome
we need think you have to go back slam
let's go back to slides so thank you as
you saw we're adding p2p to the
assistant and it will leverage the debit
cards in your Google account to send
money to friends and others and we're
just getting started
we plan to soon on board other p2p
providers brooch
so Gerard are showing some really cool
stuff that we're working on in mobile
payments in the online space we all know
that 85% of Commerce still happens in in
stores so I'd like to talk to you a bit
about how we're enhancing our merchants
facing api's to give your customers a
better in-store experience at the center
of it all is loyalty loyalty is a
connection between you the merchant and
your customers the user and we'd like to
help you with loyalty in three ways we'd
like to help you one with enrollment so
helping expose your loyalty programs to
Android pay users and signing them up to
with engagement once the Android pay
user has your loyalty card associated in
their Android pay account being able to
push offers to them that are relevant to
them first lies to them and three we'd
like to help you with easy Redemption
and earning of loyalty points and offers
so that just with a simple NFC tap what
we call a smart tap the user with
Android pay can transmit loyalty and
offer information just as easily as a
pay today with Android pay so let's look
at each of these three individually so
say I'm an Android pay user and I need
to go to Walgreens to pick up some
shampoo for my daughter of course
so Android pay will send the following
notification says faster checkout at
Walgreens add your balance rewards to
Android pay for an easier way to save
balance rewards is a loyalty program for
Walgreens and Walgreens has implemented
our smart tap technology at their
payment terminals so with a one tap on
this notification and a few things in
the Android pay app we can easily sign
up the Android pay user for the
Walgreens balance rewards loyalty
program so super exciting but we've
taken it a step further say I'm about
two words member and I'm an Android pay
user but I haven't connected my balance
of words card to my Android pay so let's
move to the demo this is cash too
the second cast
you cast a one
oh there we go
great oh that's the wrong one actually
I try some magic here Oh actually I
really need to be casted there we go oh
there we go
perfect actually these are demo slides I
guess Oh perfect I think it's a device
all right so we're on cast to now so now
I'm buying a bag of nuts and I have to
remember my phone number here I think it
was as that landline that I had four
years ago I think it was okay
now I tap
so now I've tapped the page but I've
entered my loyalty information manually
wouldn't it be magical if I would
somehow told that I can now add this
passwords card that I entered manually
into Android to automatically wow that's
pretty cool we just got a notification
from Android pay and with a single click
in the app we can now save this down to
worst card that I use manually into
Android pay so that on subsequent visits
I don't have to actually punch in my
phone number on the payment remote and
remember what my number was on that
landline years ago
so the second pillar of loyalty and the
second area we'd like to help with is
engagement how do you engage with that
customer that saved your loyalty card in
Android pay and push them offer so
they'll come back to your store for this
we have another demo with a Panera app
and the Panera loyalty program is
actually called the my Panera program so
if we can go to there we go so I'm going
to go into the Panero app in our apps
right and I'm going to click on rewards
there you go and what I'll do is I'll
save my my Panera card to Android pay by
this one click of this button great so
my my Panera loyalty card is now saved
to Android pay now if I go into Android
pay
I see the my Panera loyalty card which
is really cool when I click into it will
actually see a rich set of offers
associated with my my Panera card what's
even cooler is if I'm walking by a
Panera I will actually get a geo
notification that tells me I have offers
available to be redeemed at the Panera
Store so this is a great way in which to
engage your customers after they've
linked their loyalty program in to
Android pay and these new card links
offer api's are now available and you
guys can take a look at them at
developers.google.com slash payments so
now let's move to the last part the last
feature that we'd like to help you with
and that's the redeem loyalty
and offers at the store so I mentioned
about smart SAP we're very excited to
announce that smart SAP is also rolling
out in Singapore with ntuc link our
first international partner but more
than that we're happy announced a smart
app will be available to businesses of
all sizes including small and
medium-sized businesses and in order to
do that we partnered with clover a first
data company I'm sure you've all seen
the slicks point-of-sale and payment
terminals at your local restaurant and
cafes but the clover terminals now
support smart tap technologies to allow
for easy redemption of loyalty and
offers so I'd like to invite John Beatty
the CEO of clover to come up and tell us
a few words about the collaboration
winner please give them a party round of
applause thick thick bruised so so we at
clover are huge fans of what bruised and
Gerardo are doing here to really push
the boundaries in in commerce and
consumer experiences in commerce so
let's give these guys a hand inter
dovetails perfectly with clovers roll so
clovers mission is to enable innovation
in commerce on the merchant side now we
do this in two ways we provide open
platforms and point-of-sale and payments
to developers and then also through our
parent company first data one of the
world's leading payments technology
companies we provide broad distribution
capabilities to our vast array of
merchants both in the US and in many
many countries worldwide now we'll be
supporting smart tap in two ways first
and our open payments platform this
allows these devices here that I'll demo
here in a moment to be able to do smart
tap interactions and so we're also happy
to announce that two of our partners
shopkeep and bypass Mobile will be
building smart tap enabled experiences
through the clover platform secondly the
clover customer engagement suite of
products through that suite of products
will be enabling smart tap technology to
a vast array of our small business small
businesses in the US we've shipped over
500,000 devices to small businesses in
the US and through this consumers and
merchants will have some fantastic user
experiences now there's three things
about smart tap that I really like first
is simplicity it doesn't get simpler
than tapping to earn redeem and pay you
could hardly be simpler second it drives
real value for merchants when a customer
enrolls through smart tap what the
merchants will be able to do is push
offers and rewards directly into Android
pay for those consumers they can also
send offers if say you have a lapsed
customer and you want to incent them to
come back to your store so in its it's
really the marketing technology that I
personally want it's both convenient and
it's in context so lastly it also does
one other thing which is it enables all
sorts of other animations you can
imagine a scenario where you buy
something online it could be on the
mobile web it could be in a native app
until you buy it online and then you
want to redeem in-store pick it up
in-store you could save to Android pay
come in and then tap to present proof of
purchase there's many many other things
that we've been thinking about an online
to offline commerce and offline to
online commerce that are really enabled
by this so if you need to build anything
that touches consumers on the other side
of the counter with merchants technology
please check us out clever comm slash
developers spec to you brugge all right
thank you guys at this point I know two
things for a certain about every member
of the audience here one everyone can
use a snack right and number two
everyone wants to check out some of
these loyalty features and Android pay
that we've been talking about of course
right so we got something special for
you we've created a game called tap for
treat around IO all you have to do is
download the IO loyalty card from going
to this URL or from the i/o app and you
have to find the clover smart tap term
rolls around the venue and if you find
all five of these terminals you will get
a limited edition Android robot that
looks like me no a limited edition
Android pay bot that's not sold in
stores so highly encourage you to do
that and I'd like to see if John could
show us how the smart app works on a
clover terminal we have one right here
sure so what I have here is my phone
with the tap retreats loyalty card here
here I have a clover mini which is
fantastic customer facing payment device
happens to be based on clover OS using
AOSP and then on this side is our
merchant facing device so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to take this I'm
simply going to hold this here I'm going
to tap now you'll see here that it
welcomes me by name says welcome to
Google i/o 2017 John now one one extra
thing and this is another thing I forgot
to mention that I love about smart tap
it enables additional personalization at
the point-of-sale so over here on the
merchant side this is still a prototype
than will certainly improve this but it
has my name here you can imagine it you
can do things like Pro pull up my
previous order you know the merchant
could greet me by name ask me if I want
my usual and so I'll go ahead here and
I'm just going to check out just real
quick here
and then right here you'll be able to
see if I just refresh this that now I
have my extra loyalty points and Oh John
gets a trip out of this Dave I think you
powder and it's a smart tap terminal
right here on porch 1 so thank you very
much wonderful hey thanks everyone all
right thank you sir
Drago back to you so cool
so hopefully well John's getting a real
taste but hopefully you all have gotten
a taste of how we're making payments
faster easier and safer you've heard how
we're collaborating with a major payment
platforms like Visa MasterCard and
PayPal how we're scaling our solution by
enabling users to pay with the cards in
their Google account and how we're
helping merchants generate loyalty among
their customers through our expanded API
we can't do all this innovation by
ourselves we need all of you to
participate and we thank you for your
support
we look forward to working with you
between now and the next i/o and just to
wrap up with some final points I'm going
to turn it back to verage all right so
if you have any questions about any of
the features you've seen or any of the
demos that you've seen please go to
developers.google.com slash payments you
can get information about everything
you've seen today also these are the
listings for our office hours in our
code lab so please drop by so we can
give you some hands-on experience with
some of this technology I'd also like to
direct you to two sessions with related
content one is for Android developers
called improved sign-in payment and data
entry in your apps and one is for Chrome
developers called web payments making it
easy for users to
you money so thank you very much for
your attention and go ahead and tap for
treats thank you
[Applause]
[Music]